[Music]
Simply the Best that's perfect for her
this person now we have one of our
favorite stories of the Year revealing
the national teacher of the year winner
only on CBS mornings this year's teacher
of the year is aher Rebecca Peterson
she's a high school math teacher at
Union High School in Tulsa Oklahoma
[Applause]
for 14 years 11 of them at Union she was
she was selected for her passion for
making math exciting relevant and
accessible and for her emphasis on
learning about her students and
chronicling positive stories from her
classroom now this is the first time in
her District's history they've had a
finalist in the top five but guess what
now they have a winner Rebecca Peterson
is her name good morning congratulations
and welcome congratulations so I did
some reconnaissance they said about you
that you are you you make people not
afraid of math you actually get them to
embrace calculus that you see your
students as human that you have such a
passion and that's one of the things
that stood out and so how does it work
when you when you're notified does your
phone ring and they say hello Miss
Peterson How does it go yeah
a phone call yeah and what happened and
there's a lot of hyperventilating yes
yes and that's pretty much what I
remember
and then I remember my husband coming in
and getting to tell him and it was
truly a surreal moment did teachers play
a big role in your life when you were
growing up teachers played a massive
role in my life yeah so I'm an immigrant
to the United States and my parents are
actually medical missionaries so by the
time I was 16 I lived in four different
countries and I'm so grateful for my
Global upbringing but growing up you
know sometimes moving from continent to
continent you kind of feel like an
outsider looking in and I think
if you're on the outsider you watch the
inside very closely and those were
teachers those were teachers for me well
we're not the only ones that want to
congratulate you we have a special
surprise congratulations to you Ms
Peterson roll tape please
congratulations Rebecca for more than
anything you've walked into your
classroom and given your students the
gift of knowledge
and is both an educator and a dedicated
journaler myself I love that you share
the beautiful and positive experiences
occurring in your classroom to inspire
others and capture what it means to be a
teacher
thank you for showing the nation the
power purpose and the joy of our
profession
the president and I are so proud of you
and we can't wait to see you next week
at the White House to honor you as the
national teacher of the year
thank you
to hear that amazing it feels amazing
I'm so grateful to
to represent this incredibly powerful
profession I think my message to
teachers is still like the first two
words I learned in English thank you you
know as a child I learned from you I
believed in you walked alongside you and
I still do yeah people you what they
said about you Rebecca they were telling
me that you believe that teachers have
the power to make a bad day good that's
right I love that thinking tell me about
that that is the power of this
profession right I mean we can all think
of a teacher who held this like yeah
impact in our lives because they helped
held that power you know and I just
can't think of any other profession
where people don't just think about us
but like literally Hold Us in their
hearts for like years even decades down
the road but of course it's also
difficult because not everyone holds you
if you're teaching at the college level
right people are paying for that person
that's right but particularly in high
school at a public high school you were
trying to bring people along who don't
necessarily want to be there they are
teenagers right they have other ideas
about what's important in their life at
that time yes and when you started I was
reading that it was very difficult
really difficult and I actually started
at the college level so it was such a
shock to my system four years in
switching from college to high school
but what I say saved my career was I
started looking for the good every day
and I started writing one good thing
every day and when I took the time to
notice the good the good became better
right and it I didn't know how hard it
was going to be it's true but I also
didn't know
I love that too so Rebecca we have
another surprise
from some other people in your life who
wanted to tell you what you mean to them
they are standing by in the great state
of Oklahoma let's bring them in to say
hello those are some of your former
students in your classroom back in Tulsa
good morning guys
[Music]
[Applause]
so let's meet some of these former
classmates of yours Alyssa is one of
your 11 former students who are now also
Math teachers who've inspired teachers
to you've inspired them to become
teachers and she teaches at your old
classroom Alyssa I have to ask you what
about Rebecca made you want to follow in
her footsteps
oh my goodness it's such a good question
um I've just never had a had a teacher
like Rebecca I remember
standing In This Very Room and going
over a calculus free response question
my senior year and she she had the
boldness to come up to me and speak into
me and say Alyssa you would be so good
at this job and I just remember thinking
about the way that she made me and the
rest of her students feel and it's a
feeling like no other
um I really admire the way that she was
willing to let people in she was just
willing to let her students into her
life she brought in so much
vulnerability
um
and just fold this into the classroom
and flush you know I remember my senior
year her telling me that she was
pregnant and it was so exciting Flash
Forward a couple years her son is a ring
bearer in my wedding and yeah and she's
celebrating with me through that so it's
just been such a beautiful thing that
really came from just yeah just that
simple connection that she made in the
classroom and it really did make such a
big difference in my life
well so in addition to Alyssa you've
also got somebody else there uh Kayden
who told us this is really moving he
says that you changed the trajectory of
his life Caden talked to us about that
what impacted Miss Peterson have on you
absolutely um it's it's very similar to
Miss Fisher's and that Miss Peterson
kind of
recognized a love for teaching that I
had but that I didn't recognize and she
sent an email to my mom unprompted which
was so sweet that my mom was like crying
over it and she kind of guided me and
encouraged me to start teaching myself
and and showed me the ways that she
teaches and gave me gave me advice on
how to have like compassion for my
students and and that has changed my
life that helped me discover what I want
to do with my life that's helped me get
involved with lots of community
activities I've been involved with since
then it has made more of a difference
than I think she could ever know the the
support and and encouragement that she
gave me to follow this passion
yes and she did that with me I'm getting
teary-eyed I don't have fond memories of
my math teacher so I'm so glad to see
that you were so loved and that you love
your job so much I love them so much
clearly they love you back make me want
to re-enroll in high school
I could use some remedial math actually
Rebecca Peterson uh you were a teacher
of the year you do that now the world
knows that congratulations
congratulations so wonderful we'll be
right back
I was